president biden being accused and
criticized for total hypocrisy
he has reopened the exact same child
migrant detention center in texas that
he wants himself bashed the trump
administration for operating
i'm harris faulkner you are in the
faulkner focus you may recall
then candidates joe biden and kamala
harris tore into president trump on the
campaign trail for operating border
facilities
for migrant children coming into our
nation illegally
but now the white house seems to think
those facilities are fine
necessary the white house is defending
its decision to
renew those facilities calling it a
temporary fix for social distancing
requirements during the pandemic
white house press secretary jinsaki says
the intense criticism of the trump
administration
doesn't apply now
kamala harris said that this facility
putting people in this facility was a
human rights abuse committed by the
united states government and jill biden
said
under trump there have been horrifying
scenes of order
at the border of kids being kept in
cages now it's not under trump it's
under buy
this is not kids being kept in cages
even democratic congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez tweeted this
this is not okay never has been okay
never will be okay
no matter the administration or party
kristen fisher is live for us at the
white house
on this top story kristen hey harris
well this is the first
migrant child facility to be opened
under the biden administration but
even that name is being criticized
because this same facility was
open for one month during the trump
administration but back then
it was called a tent city where kids
were kept in cages
now harris you mentioned that criticism
from congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez
but this is an issue where there is
truly bipartisan criticism take a look
at this you've got democratic congress
congressman jamal bowman who says
regardless of who's in the white house
the words migrant facility for children
shouldn't be in our government's
vocabulary
and then there's republican jim jordan
who tweeted they're not kids in cages
anymore
they're kids in migrant facilities what
changed
well the white house says what's changed
is that over the last few weeks
there's been a tremendous surge in
unaccompanied minors arriving at the
border
nearly 6 000 were apprehended in january
alone
so you take that and combine it with
coronavirus related restrictions and the
biden white house says
they had no choice but to reopen it but
the white house press secretary jensachi
insists
this time it's different because the
biden administration is not separating
families at the border
it is not a replication certainly not
that's
that is never our intention of
replicating the immigration policies of
the past administration
but we are in a circumstance where we
are not going to expel unaccompanied
minors at the border
that would be inhumane so the white
house is saying that the reopening of
this facility in texas
is only temporary but the more
longer-term
housing options which are run by the
office of refugee resettlement
are approaching capacity and harris
there are no signs that this surge of
unaccompanied minors at the border
is letting up anytime soon harris
kristen thank you very much